[Music] what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we are here to enter the
pizzeria for Five Nights at Freddy's couldn't be
more excited John are you excited I am excited
I've been in the ball pit I'm stuffed with pizza
let's get animatronic ladies and gentlemen I'm
going to tell you right away that if you're here
to watch two dudes catch all the crazy Easter eggs
and references you've come to the right place
get them all you are watching the wrong channel
for that I know like some of the lore I've of
course like played the game like a little bit
with Friends by no means the experts that you
guys are going to be looking for all right for
the most part it's going to be pretty new for us
on all accounts you know I see that critics are
not on the positive side but fans are loving
it let's see where we ride the line or better
sentences let's ride the line pleas everybody all
righty guys well leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also be sure to subscribe click
that notification Bell as always full length
R and watch along you sync up with your own copy
of Five Nights at Freddy's we of course watching
us on the peock that is available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page we cover several
things exclusive over there with the highlights
and watch songs included let's Swing Away action
[Music]
people security camera
glitch oh how much batter has
left what's interesting opening
shot oh he's trying to escape oh
goody it's time
spooky it really brought this set to life damn
yeah they at the celebrate poster monitors I
love a good Eerie ventilation claustrophobic
[Music] shot come to security guard watch the
animatronics a man they're like in the Next
Room dumbass you deserve to
die awesome is that fox
oh hell
yeah yeah
buddy oh let's go hello security guard this is
spotting sweet sauce take Old Red
Eyes oh I love how this I love the
design so [Music] far sprung in a trap nicely
put [Music]
oo golly this is kind of Ian 80s horror music
sawes [Music] too Scott cin you never imagine
the Empire you would have now when you're
trying to make Christian video games that
photo they're all here I love all the drawings oh
cool nice even for my extremely limited knowledge
there's a lot of recognizable imagery here
mhm the graphics this way be the perfect
Gateway the 83
one it's crazy how this did start spring from
like a independent game into
what it's become yeah some guy
DIY Dream Theory oh my god he has drawings
too come on let's go 5 minutes I need you dressed
that shot shows us this is going to be from aby's
point of view and though the dreamer remains
asleep he walks through memory as if experiencing
it for the first time a new in the theme stated
cuz I don't want it to melt the ice cream and
can I get some whipped cream on top and three
cherries follow your security instincts you want
your usual right uh yeah did you shoot this whole
thing like a dream in a way yeah we got this new
flavor I think he's just grabbing his son I don't
think it's a kidnapping he's just an Angry Dad
hey oh but did someone in his pass go missing whoa
whoa damn oh damn he just throwing down number 27
it was 2,000 he could be using this rage though to
take on animatronics drinking punch pop while he
does it y y here we go you ain't no Steve Raglin
liar liar you're a phony what is your deal Mike
would you some kind of head case you beat up
a man in broad daylight in front of his child
who went missing in your life it's like you're
not even trying here you sit before me asking
for help you know Mike is the perfect victim
I am just trying to figure out who you are Mr
Michael oh are they related is he Michael are
they going to go with it coffee sorry I thought
they completely changed it maybe that was a
hint that they are I'm going to be brutally
honest with you here Mike given your track
record your options are going to be extremely
limited you know it's not that easy love
watching Matthew Lillard I have a job for
you come on sit down I think the acting
is great so far though it's a security
gig B disclosure it's not great you get to
Be Your Own Boss sort of and you only have
to worry about one thing keeping people out
and keep the place tidy that's two things oh
he is perfect yeah he's perfect for you want
the job or not how's the pay not great the
hour is or he's had this conversation
before Oh many times I can't do night
look like he's going to cry that's such
a shame wait uh Cas you have a change
of heart is Matthew L really
tall or is Josh Hutson really
short Matthew Lillard is of average
height Josh Hutson is Tiny thanks for
babysitting the loudest crayon that good looking
guy I recognize who are all these other punks
my friends are the ghosts of the children
communicating with her you know I wouldn't
be surprised this is a blem house movie can you
just eat some food sitting on my friend but you
should know what happens to little kids who don't
eat their dinners their bodies stay the same size
forever oh my God oh my God foreshadowing it
away yes when you're compacted down inside of
a machine my friend says you're an idiot at
least I'm real oh my God for shadowing and
away he's listening to a Walkman mhm hey man
cassette tapes are coming [Music] back pining for
fun great transition damn how about some
burger with that ketchup on everything's
better swimming a ketchup like this child POV
they do a lot of the povs from the children
go watch your brother okay okay his brother okay
is it going to be different from what I remember
happens Garrett oh no go punch the driver
okay so he was kidnapped that's the trauma
he wasn't watching him the counselors weren't
paying attention Garrett and now he's got to
make up for it by looking after Abby and every
time he looks at her he just sees him although
I feel like if I was shoved into the back of some
rando's car I would be panicking a little harder
from what I recall Mike's brother accidentally
got him killed at that was the 83 oh yeah yeah
yeah where he gets bit by fredd the bite of 83
but Mike's also the son of Aton I have really
tried to play nice I have but I have to think
about Abby now enough is enough Doug oh he's
fighting for custody of her okay you know that
this is the right thing to do she doesn't even
care about Abby all she wants is the monthly
check from the state when did Josh Hutcherson's
voice evolve into Aaron Paul good question you
know pictures hold tremendous power for children
images are the most important tool we have for
understanding the world around us the creepier
the better you pictures mean something and who
is at the center of nine out of 10 of them like
it or not you're her world but what if it's not
up to me you're going to prove that through this
journey okay the camera that you saw said
2,000 but this feels way older yeah with
a lot of it production design choices yeah I
was just calling to see if that job that you
offered was still available oh it absolutely
is no one wants that job we had to change a
heart how soon could I start tonight yeah
buddy this place was huge in the ' 80s with
kids been shut down for years the owner is a bit
of a he's kind of a Sentimental guy I guess he
having so much fun just can't bring himself to let
it go [Music] yet yeah he is excellent it's just
like when you're getting briefed at the beginning
of the game and the ju the position of their two
performances is wonderful security systems dated
but fully functional uh-huh lights on the outside
cameras inside and outside the electricity is
a bit iffy the [Music] cameras how great must
it have been to bring this set to life oh man
people must have been geeking out throughout the
production ready to rock there's a breaker in the
main office just flip it let's hope that comes in
[Music] handy no do not awaken
the Beast just keep your eyes on
the monitors and and keep people out I'll be right
B mom's going to so pissed at me
piece of cake is it now uhoh the
switch it's aesthetically really neat I will
catch you on the flip side hopefully the flip side
died oh you're clever you're clever with your
words my friend God that look send another
one to his Doom I'm partially worried Matthew
Lillard's not going to be in it that much more
yeah I could see but I think he brings there's
so much presence to his performance he's like
playing it just villain enough but enough where
he would have suspect he's up to something yeah he
seems like kind of an odd dude welcome to Freddy
Fazbear's pizzeria where fantasy and fun come to
life they haven't been able to update this video
familyfriendly fun and cuttingedge animatronic
technology yes of course enables our characters
to interact with guests in truly liike fashion
while cleverly concealed nice let's introduce
you to the stars of the show the band Yes yeah
with the face flash adorable aren't they did
they cut it out I love that that they don't
even even show up in the video first here to
Delight Dazzle and entertain for years [Music]
to that's balloon
boy yes the last suit you'll ever
wear [Music]
I love how that exit sign constantly feels
like they're calling to you get out while you
can it's a very [Music] voyerism I
don't know if it's the movies doing or
my knowledge of the game but it's making
me like not look at our main character
and everything else definely who's lurking
yeah which of these murals isn't a [Music]
mural yes they're all here let's rock cupcake
chica who's that uh it's uh
it's Will's Wonderland right
that's the creepiest
time take this one book with me wherever I
go I keep trying to read dream theory
but I keep falling asleep whatever I do
everything's better swimming and ketchup
right M oh you going to save him this
time they're all yeah what is
this who are you it's a lot earlier in the
movie than I expected it to be you see what
happened oo cool did you see who took my
brother wait no interesting they're
immediately assing the personalities to [Music]
them that's kind of clever tripping w wake
up but they are just teasing my mind zigzags
between like the first time watching a movie and
also like the little things I know yeah totally
I'm like oh if I didn't know that would I be
like what's going on here who are these kids
or would I've immediately Associated it being
part of the animatronics I mean you'd have to
assume that something is a Miss five creepy kids
and even in a dream cut to the static on the
moners spark a welcome to sparkies can I
set you folks up with some appetizers oh
well that's no fun you do realize that
lunch is the most important meal of
Day game theory his voice sounded familiar at
first but know but it wasn't thought it was
breakfast some people say that but you know it's
just a theory a game theory oh man don't ask me
to recognize any other YouTubers that may appear
don't worry Sniper Wolf is about to show up be
great yeah that's the one we need he really needs
this new job look good on paper for the judge us
treacherous [__] you deserve to die his job is
to make sure nobody gets in so we get in oh my God
we got victims damn let's do this judge gives you
the kid and you give us $2,000 1,000 wow it's all
their want is 2,000 for that know that so cheap
so cheap like aim a little higher gang I'm coming
with you no no you're not I'm coming with you why
why do you want to go maybe because he can watch
her there and it's probably a cool place for a
kid in theory a film Theory she's got some mental
spiritual connection to the victims or that night
two the other thing is every incidental character
that shows up I'm now like coffin don't remember
what he looks like I think if we just freak out at
everyone we don't write Rec we'll get the job done
yeah just never be specific about who they are
yeah that looks like
Foxy or Bonnie I guess big
ears Garrett it's interesting that
changes in perspective each time
too to this dream don't run okay I I just
want to know what you saw great lens help
me whoa that one kid's face the
blur whoa
foxy there you go there's a
nightmare
it's [Music] time it's me oh
good oh what oh oh no she's
here to explain that there's a
history of security guards that tend to go
missing or die you're bleeding by the way
you're flirting by the way a very demure police
officer I know where they keep it for Save kit
that is a cut guess where that gash came from why
Nebraska oh you need a hand huh clever cuz of the
hook Freddy's on my beat I like to stay
well informed I believe you Al I really
love the place as a kid that's why I became a
cup I keep an eye on the old Freddy's Vanessa
shell Mike Mary Shelly do we freak out do
we do we know that just in case damn I can't
believe it she's really real you've been acting
suspicious since the moment you opened the door
uh well look it's been a weird night and it's
like a rainstorm in this creepy old building
with power issues sounds like Freddy's oh sh
she knows so much more than she's letting on
this place it gets to people it's one of the
reasons why you're going to quit you never
last does she think they all just
quit yeah I'm like what do have you
not looked further into that have you met
them yet or are you part of it add to that
the thing of there kids going missing
kids missing prepare to have your mind
blown five children went missing
awesome this this is the best thing you've
seen in your entire life yeah
definitely what I was going to
say want to dance [Music] a no
maybe some other time show only plays
Once a Night you're a weird weird weird
cop my thoughts excited play this with
such mystery you said some kids went
missing back in the 80s what happened
to them it was big news that's why the
place shut down you're not up on your 80s
headlines you're not even wearing your
badge you're
marked well that was a very normal
altercation so strange don't let
this place get to you just do your job
and you'll be fine nah uh-huh nah you're
a ghost you're the spirit of one of
the kids or some or another notable
character oh thank God we're finally going to
get some deaths let's do it my Carnage my PG-13
Carnage yes let's go maximum damage minimum
time oh yeah you see anything valuable grab
it good yeah golden yeah $200 each here we come
man we'll be eating good for a couple of weeks
boys oh those employees of the
month love the little cuts of the
security cameras showcasing creeping up on them
what game is on your shirt
like Frogger or something oo
nice I actually missed it
first in a situation like this I would
always get another person yeah and then we
can both open the scary cab oh thank God it's
nothing it really sets my nerves at [Music]
ease awesome cool
angle whoa the life flashlight whoa
no let seat whoa don't kill not Anton yelin face
nice yes that was appropriately creepy
fun yes nice what the hell
are you doing cool it's well
Incorporated there's a child
Soul trapped in that door handle
come on you went into the right
closet be there Clyde bye-bye
Bonnie [Music]
o
Hank interesting they getting mileage out
of showcasing them it's interesting cuz they
they've like whoa all my game tokens why did
Jack so many tokens what is the value of the
that $200 cut work at any arcade get up the
phone in the screaming it's interesting yeah
that they they've taken a whoa that they're
making them like really front and center
it's like they've taken a gradual buildup to
featuring them but they're not doing as much
like teasing and suspense and just showing them
now that they're here yeah it's not what I I
expected [__] I mean they're the most expensive
part of putting this movie together
so yeah you got to on that's a great
shot o yeah I mean the direction aggressive
POV Punchy but reserved when it needs to be do
they intentionally made the exit sign look
pixelated
yes especially for the first
big sequence to be in the day is
interesting follow me don't leave the getaway
vehicle this way oh it's just a video
game character want to help you this
way these eyes cry every night [Music] warmer how
in the heck heck that's what the re-shoot
to make a PG-13 four the flip is going on
here
yes this is wise are you being
lured in or are you just guess
got to check it out got to got to
investigate come on bite do the
[Music]
bite hey that was that was that was a surprising
amount of violence for it's a Nifty way to get
your Carnage into PG-13 package I am GNA take
you to work okay appreciate how exasperated
he is I am Desiring a little bit more Nuance in
their Dynamic yeah he's either just dejected or
they're being randomly really playful yeah made
a mess sorry oh Dan James I hate her she's mean
and she smells like cigarettes yeah I know it's
nice that we can finally agree about something
yeah are you going to give me away give me away
give me away give me away now like that they
dressed her like Olive Oil from Popeye you're
two whacked outs remember to lock a freaking
door you're liable you wouldn't understand the
moment I file that report it's out of my hands
fall cops work this way so I used to have a
brother his name was Garrett he was uh he was
taken oh was that what we've seen five times oh
that's what that was been so confused the whole
time every single thing that you see gets stored
inside of you it's called memory you just have
to know how to look I'd like to believe that and
I know that he's in here but he's just he's it's
buried and I go back to that same memory and I
I search for details why don't you try to like
do hypnosis with like a professional I know what
crazy looks like Mike this isn't it a you and Abby
you still have each other from where I said I'd
say you're lucky you're about to get even luckier
when I tell you what just went down at Freddy's
should go yeah you're a cop who seems to waste a
lot of their time when you're at Freddy's you
stay alert what what what about if he needs to
sleep another time come on Max come on that's a
sensible way to make it so he has to take her to
work not going to lie the critics made this sound
like this was like an egregiously terrible film or
something it could have a bit more flavor but so
far it's pretty good yeah you're not here to have
fun okay slow down slow down slow down Abby yeah
some of the dialogue is a little wooden it feels
and like even in that scene with her the cop I'm
like she just learned what we've known the past
hour yeah the main thing about this character
has just been vocalized wound reiterated I mean
in a lot of ways it does kind of feel like
the the Blum House movie version you might
expect night
three smudge
boy cool shot they emptied out the prizes
so she didn't file a report no I suppose
not I guess this place looks cleaner than
before they broke okay I replaced all the
glass and now he's earned their
respect yeah because he cares for
Freddy's Abby you've got a new friend
Abby guess you really didn't need those
pills I would love it if this
movie actually kills her off it
would be bold it would be so cool child
death child death I know you're back
there
nope how they sound like cyborgs yeah I
don't know how it's possible that you're
here like this in my dream but it's
all the electrical interference help
me remember the man who took my brother
love how we just accepted this if we show
you what will you give us pizza Abby
oh Abby I'll give you anything you
want shouldn't have made it so vague
man whoa happy whoa oh my God not wasting any
time nice POV what do you think
you're doing they wouldn't stop
tickling me said I was going to die that's my
friend oh come on I want you to meet the
others this is a different direction than
I was expecting they let the other ones
be the victims he's going to team up
with them Bonnie foxy and Chica what
about cupcake this is Mike hi Mike this
is a joke right I mean there's someone
here there's dude your job got way more
interesting it's okay Mike I just want to
[Music] play we have to go home
now come on hold on here's my
home address here's where to find us if you need
anything had a lot of fun tonight thank you
for playing with me very considerate young lady
yikes [Music]
oh [Music] bye I mean one part
of me would have be like this is
kind of cool it's like Discovery the
teenage M Ninja Turtles in away yeah
I mean they didn't rip me up they're
they're you're hanging kept my sister
entertained all right I need
to go back to sleep I got to
get back to to that clearing talk to those kids
again homie how are you not
freaking out and let's trying
to understand what the hell you just
witnessed yeah you just you just saw
some unprecedented [__] just now so
the kids have been communicating with
her all the totems so those uh those machines my
friends does this guy only sleep when he's on the
job it seems I feel like he should be sleeping now
yeah should be sleeping in the afternoon are they
ghosts of course else could they make the robots
move I love how simple she has digested this kids
man they got the imagination you know it's it's a
whole different thing you know we used to have a
brother right Garrett we still do I don't really
talk about him very much neither did mom or dad
who are the birthing lives of these what a full
on adult and she's like like five yeah how long
ago did Mom and Dad disappear you drew that
right who told you about that was it a a boy
with blonde hair clearly ever tell you anything
about the man driving that car I drew him who do
you think took him oh it's Matthew Lillard come
on it's got to be Matthew Lillard of course or
the cop I wonder if that's why the after name
stood out to him not the after name why Mike's
last name stood out to him yeah whatever yeah
I don't know if you just recognized him from
recognizing his brother's last name because
they're obviously changing the background on
that yeah Mike is not the son of him so maybe
this is a way for him to tie up a loose end now
yeah damn what the hell is her connection to this
Abby if I asked you to wait in the car would you
no guys I'm back Abby hey Vanessa this Vanessa
cop doesn't do any actual cooping nope I miss
you guys you knew about this I'm Vanessa
downtime cop it's a sleepy town you know
there's not much going on guess you figured it
out ghost children possessing giant robots how
is there no like why isn't anyone a little
freaked out by the reality of this and the
fact that they're just here just like yeah
we're we're I like the plot Direction but
there's something about the response that's
like making me a little bit like what what
the emotional dynamics of this are a bit funky
yeah I think we could use the tables for the fort
what is happening I like that it's a misleading
pleasantry yes that it's capturing this like
childlike Wonder to it you know what I mean
is he going to like join them by the end and
they're just going to go around the country
like swallowing up bad people he needs to be
higher you did
it what are you okay what is happen
I like it in here me too fascinating
I can feel this being at odds with who to aim this
movie at I used to keep him back here
for big events remind me how you know
[Music] that they tend to be pretty unstable let's
see that's a spring of trap I think this movie was
just in need of a little restructuring if they
introduced this earlier sure and this quality
and then you're like oh I guess they're fun
and kids in there but then oh wait no they're
Sinister then yeah the Sinister evolves kind of
like a Megan in a way yeah no no yeah it's like
do we trust this a little bit no this is making
our lives better this is bringing us together
this is improving our relationship oh wait they
just killed the other side of our family did you
ask them about this yeah I tried I don't think
they like me very much let's go all you do is
sleep well you don't try to get to know them
you need to drop this I don't really see how
that's any of your business I'm telling you
you need to let it go how how I mean they're
baiting her in like they want to they want to
kill her yeah they want her soul that's wait
talk to me I'm trying you're not listening
please finding the guy that did this is the
only thing matters to me I mean Abby also
matters to you yeah Abby nah they're going
to use your essence for youth juice that
stuff's called Abby CH just Hing over so
sorry Remnant you can do whatever you want with
your own life but if you ever bring Abby back
here again I will shoot you w wow seems like
one of them was related to her yeah wow there's
my favorite little girl this is not dude you
shouldn't have like trap her like this I promise
you this is not what you think it is I hate you
hate you Mike not helping the custody case yep
surprise uhoh oh no they're going to turn on him
now when you do get back you and me are going to
have a little chat he gets back you're going
to have a little dead you know what works for
me a warm glass of milk with Cam meal and honey
I tell you jeez man what an [__] there's some
great Sounders on and I think that guy's a cameo
that we definitely recognize oh yes also Scott
cin study the cameras I could use a little bit
more tension and suspense yes it seems to not
a heck of a lot of that this movie doesn't seem
like it really wants to scare that much attension
doesn't exactly equate to scary like it's not
really what I'm even asking for it's just put
suspense you want to feel dread I want feel you
feel nervous I want to feel something yeah hey
buddy just stand there take in you got a bowl of
ketchup here for you this isn't how it happened
this isn't real memor is rewriting itself you want
to save Garrett that's why you're really here well
to change what happened of course to go back
I can't kid became precocious they're all gone
really so come live the rest of your
life in a dream you can be together
with him again like before but only
here in this specific scenario we want
Abby what's more important to you she loves
them you've seen her with them e it's time to
let her go sweetheart you were never the right
person to take care of her he this is a little
twisted yeah I like to see okay yes don't give
the creepy blonde child what it wants I can't
believe he agreed to that he's so driven
by this no this is wrong I don't want this
[Music] this you leave Abby
alone see I feel like the most mood and
atmosphere comes whenever we're here yeah
isn't that awesome stay away from my sister
and I feel like the direct oo is actually more
interested in this [__] yeah I wonder if this
director has like an Indi drama background or
something claw The Hook fighting
D leis from Gangs of New
York oh looking up at the trees
pining scoop let's go hello [Music]
Michael you have wasted your life
for years is hunting down your
brother neglecting the sister very real beside
you well we escaped that pretty easily
yeah you just headed H the button you
know and just who right out found the
dead bodies whoa that's a good gor
gag oh now it's becoming the trailer yeah now
first hour of this big trippy sort of Dreamscape
[Music] film that humming always gets me oh nice
he's always getting out of things in the nick of
time what okay going Offroad Freddy Freddy's
ability to travel is incredible yeah why do
you just stay confined to the pizzeria it's
time to go play It's All For You Dam they
just they play so much more to like oh my God
already she fell asleep how do we get there I
play so much more to the ghostly element than
I expected them to yeah than like the actual
murderous mechanical side they did this mystery
all in a weird order that guy oh my goodness
what why do I always get the
weirdos also a notable Cameo woo when and doubt
make a weird moment funny yep instead of really
acknowledging that's the closest we I think we've
gotten to someone being like this is disturbing
they tried to kill me vessa but I'm guessing you
already knew that yeah who are you brother you
knew about them too right oh boy it's complicated
more complicated than possessed robots murdering
innocent people they weren't innocent Abby is
you don't know Abby are you even a cup what
do they want with my sister they want to make
her like that yes feel like that was kind of
clear that's a great shot yeah come on let's go I
feel like this movie thinks it's doing a mystery
but the mystery is just so freaking obvious yeah
like we're so L do the movie and I'm like well
yeah and if we just have a Bas level understanding
of the game like I wonder what an expert is going
to be thinking about watching a lot of this
in the 80s when those kids went missing police
searched Freddy's from top to bottom except for
inside the animatronics the man who took them he
was a very bad man nice lens FL parents would
cry and the police would come looking and he
knew there's one place they never think to check
because why would they because they're cops it's
not just their ghosts that are inside of those
machines they're actual physical bodies is their
bodies he influences them somehow whoas oh
Matthew Lillard but it's too late now he knows
that you're looking for him think you could have
warned him more specific way you need to tell me
who he is he is a very frustrating character
yeah he looks like this he's free and he also
gives people career jobs is William Aton William
Aton he's my father oh snap there you go that's
why oh dang you knew not about Garrett at least
not when we met oh I'm so so sorry tell me how to
stop them tell me how to save my sister I mean
he wouldn't know she wouldn't know would she I
don't think so I mean maybe but I don't know
if she's going to tell him she does [Music]
know we use these for animal control
woo if he's there I I won't be any
use to you spring trp he really messed
you up didn't he he's a psychopath of
course yes clearly gave you your dead
kidnapped Brother's airplane to play
with I mean I guess like structurally it's
kind of just strange of like it's supposed
to be this bombshell of a reveal but in the movie
world we only just learned about William Aton 5
seconds before she said it yeah so it's not
like a crazy twist you know I feel like the
bigger reveal just seems to be like oh she's his
daughter she's the daughter of whoever is doing
this like they don't set up William Aton earlier
for that there's no buildup on who he
is for us to be like oh diabolical you
know must have been
nothing I love how these kids seem
so freaking normal but then they just
behave like let's just fulfill the roles of
the animatron yeah let's just wait here and
let's do our song and occasionally if anybody
breaks in then we'll Feast on their souls and
flesh water use the element that brings life yes
CH where are we going going
to get you a new body [Music]
okay time has been bought well
done chica I don't like this you
will get in kid Abby it's one just
for you let me go oh no leave her
alone oh right in the ey job hold done
this guy's a great shot he should have
been a cop yourself yeah serious eat this
I've been stuck trying to fix the past but
you are the most important thing in the
world to me and I promise you I'm going
to do better have this conversation somewhere
else have this conversation outside come on
so
creepy freaking cupcake it's the
worst one of the most yeah it's
the freakiest one it's the
most DED it's like an evil
Pac-Man no it's kind of a neat shot
the spirit descends the body arises
that's a burnt
[Music]
cupcake just paint a big tunnel on one of
the walls like the Road Runner
would do run right into [Music]
it foxy looks like starwolf
that horror movie limp D Mike you
are taking these things down pretty
effectively uhoh hell yes let
go Aon has got to be in there
yeah o yeah I see some beard under
there yeah he's spring trapping it
[Music]
oh oh no oh it's okay
foxy oh she's still concerned I know
they're still our friends first I
killed your brother now I kill
you yeah symmetry my friend go to
hell wake up
children E I have something for you to play
with nice stand up to your dad little ones tell
me you have a sister she will
love it here you however are
finished that's enough drop the knife he is
the creepiest one they saved
him for last and it is really
creepy a you may have forgotten your loyalties
but I assure you they have [Music] not oh my God
Stew's the killer the whole time secret sequel
we both know your you're not going to use a gun
oh devour him if you're going to kill
me put me in an animatronic the yellow
rabbit he controls them the drawings they
even did the EO onio it's good we needed
it you had one job keep him in the dark
kill him if he got too close that's two
jobs that's all your whole thing man you
always say one job you give people two
jobs
yes Voodoo crayons let go I
won't let you hurt her too
yeah that was nice that's cool hey I bet she's
still alive ooh what have
you done I have the power
now oh [__] he murdered us they know
what you did move move shining a light
on the truth look at you look at
the nasty things that you have
become no you are wretched rot
little beast I made you combine
yes o
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
yeah this movie makes up for a
lot with great sound design too oh
yeah good becomeing yes I always come back of
course he does play unhinged extraordinarily
well cuz he's a psychopath but you could hear the
hit to the former debonaire kind of
quality that he used to have you know
of the wealthy man yeah the showman who
would be responsible for something like
this whoa
it's interesting that their eyes become red
when they've learned the truth and been set
free Freddy's just crumbling and then
it just crumble yeah crumbles into the
Earth I have a prediction what the turn she's
taken these past few weeks balloon boy is going
to show up ah I bet you're right the only one
small enough to be everywhere what do you want
for dinner pizza or spaghetti good thing
they killed the ant yes solve one problem
yeah completely freed us of that burden we're
going to make a quick stop okay and no one's
investigating that murder andessa I don't know if
you can hear any of this she's dreaming now yeah
fall asleep next door I don't think that either
of us would be here today if it weren't for you
even though you did lead us pretty well into
danger so get better I love you we're a family
now you okay no no why why would you put that
up there can we visit them sometime you know
what you never know what can happen this movie
could be a hit maybe we could get a part two
do you think drinking up and know if you just
turn into a cow could open that sister location
yet
oh
that is
Eerie game
over what an interesting movie oh oh I think this
is a yoav song yeah Living Tombstone Liv tomstone
that's what it's called that's what it's called
yeah this is huge for them damn that's awesome
first thing on the credits not bad there's got to
be a postcards oh no oh no my dude not today sorry
do you live in this car this poor man I said re
the balloon [Laughter] boy that was pretty good
balloon boy coming to play okay guys if you are
listening to this on Apple and Spotify we just
watched Five Nights at Freddy's literally just
finished watching it and we are going to talk
about it right now most death and I got to say
like one thing that I was loving when looking at
this is wow what a great merch advertisement
yes you know what I mean most definitely and
then I thought about like just how great the
real rejects merch has been as of late reject
Nation sh C and yeah so we're wearing like
two the RR apparels right now but then we've
also got some great ones like we have the space
babies of the Galaxy we got the Child Protection
Services recently launched America's ass and
then we also got some Ahsoka inspired te's
as well and a whole bunch of other ones we got
some Last of Us inspired ones thank you to all
who have been purchasing the RR merch is ones
that we are creatively involved with ourselves
and so it means the world whenever people well go
because it's one of it's one of the absolute best
way to support the channel it's my favorite way
for people to support the channel personally so
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool wait for
that day where I see a tea in the Wild on
somebody who's not any of us yeah and then they
don't know the what real reject wa for for them
to be like no I saw somewhere in the shirt and I
wanted to buy it so I went to the store know who
influences the influencers you know you didn't
even know reject Nation shop was something tied
to some YouTube channel just always felt like a
reject in the nation that I live in so I bought
a bunch of real reject shirts specifically
but I didn't realize there was a channel I
don't know why they spelled the real world I hate
reaction videos I don't like boies really can I
return this but I really am rejected by most
people I mean um all right well John um yes
what' you think I thought this was a strange
and interesting experience you'd be nice man
there a rabid fan base out there they will tear
you limb from limb closer to that the games are
like that what the movie will do some kind of
gearbox yeah uh I no I mean you got to kind of
respect it a little bit like in the sense of that
I understand fandoms can be very sensitive they've
been wanting this for a very long time oh yeah
they clamor at the bit for it and I understand
that you know they they're probably wants
to eat this all up way more yeah and and so
yeah what is your take on it factoring that in no
totally I mean this definitely also be extremely
on sugarcoat your extreme hesty your authenticity
I thought this was a very fun movie experience uh
it's not what I expected it's it's definitely
a strange movie however I can't pretend like
I wasn't Giddy and and enjoying seeing the
characters come to life spending time inside
of Freddy's and just thinking of the promise that
this property has you know beyond just one movie
um yeah this is in some ways like the blumhouse
take on Five Nights at Freddy's that you might
expect the execution is like kind of peculiar
and curious to me uh and I'm you know kind of I'm
excited to kind of bat it back and forth with you
right now but um as it stands I'm not 100% like
that's exactly the experience I was hoping for
but at the same time it was always intriguing no
matter what and sometimes it was being effectively
creepy and uh and you know nodding to the games in
ways that were obviously very fun uh and in other
ways I was scratching my head a little bit as to
like what the true intent was and what was maybe
uh more Twisted before like I think the thing
is I think this movie is in kind of a strange
position because I think it has to play towards
a very wide age range these games are rated teen
it has a very dark Grim Twisted lore that lends
itself to an R-rated experience so I think this
movie's impact kind of gets muddled in between
all that um but I had a good time regardless I
don't think this movie needs to be M methan no
I think it's I think in terms of an actual movie
it's not a great comparison I do I do think though
that methan is a PG-13 blumhouse film yes it
is that did it exceptionally well and didn't
feel to PG13 even though it works way it's like
when I was watching this sometimes you know you
might watch something you go you start rewriting
it in your head and you're thinking about what you
would have done differently and I don't re when
I was when I say that I'm not even thinking to
myself what would I do to rewrite it in terms of
here's what I would change about this character
that's not that I would really I'm like I would
just kind of rearrange the placement and unveiling
of how a lot of it was done so it could actually
be effective because for the most part I didn't
really feel much tension I I didn't really find
it exciting I didn't really find it suspenseful it
and it was kind of like in intermittent yeah um it
wasn't that funny not that I was like walking in
expecting a laugh I I just I I do feel that like
it nor is it nor do I have strong feelings about
anything that is egregiously bad you know like
that yeah it's neither especially good nor bad I
found it to be very very mid to a high low with
an occasional like honestly like the the parts
that I thought saying the most were a little bit
more The Oddities that were not advertised um
like like some of the dream moments perhaps I
mean I I can imagine how that feel you know and
and was was strange to me is like for the most
part the the lore that they explored did not mean
to rhyme but maybe I got more when talking about
the lore let's open up the door and see what's
at the Freddy store Okay so the at the um now
now now I'm so caught up in what I just did that
I don't remember talking John please stop stop me
somebody stop me um before my thoughts wash theore
uh what we talking about the unexpected part these
parts are not cut up John we need to remember the
unexpected parts of the lore you said were things
that were more oh yeah no uh uh actually well no
I mean what I'm saying is not even unexpected it
was it was that I mean the only thing expect it
was like the Vanessa thing which I don't think
is part of the actual lore uh I I doubt because
to my recollection it's uh Afton has two kids and
Mike and his brother yeah and then brother is the
one who dies in 83 yeah Mike Plays this trick on
him and then yeah gets mangled up by Freddy yeah
yeah so they really obviously change that right
got make him sympathetic and then um and then you
had them killing after and then there's a whole
thing with like a William and I think the other
guy's like it's not Hank I think it's like Hank
or Henry some other guy who partnered up with
partner yeah they had like a after those makes
his animatronics his robotics company and all that
my point being is that most of the lore that like
for someone like me who doesn't who would be like
don't ask me I'm I'm still like no actually kind
of was aware of most of what they explored here
yeah yeah if you have a friend like i' I've got
a couple friends who are very dedicated and and
immersed in five nights and through them over the
years I have been exposed to a lot of this stuff
and and so it was enough for for me to at least
grip most of what was happening yeah so none
of it was like unexpected lore or surprising
or something I haven't heard before already so my
my point with that is like in in a way it could
it could have also played to M and I I wouldn't I
wouldn't tout myself as like one of those I'm not
by know means a super fan or or some big fan of
like Five Nights at Freddy's to the point where
it's going to naturally play on some type of rency
or Nostalgia for Five Nights at Freddy the way how
I'm hearing it's plating to people out in the in
the cinemas when they're watching it and they're
like freaking out about references and things tied
in and oh my God they brought they translated it
from animation game to Big you know uh uh I'm
I'm thinking just in terms of like an actual
movie that they that they made you know and I
think for as a movie that they made I thought
the trailers were way more exciting and and when I
talk about the placement of stuff I have no issue
with anything that they actually threw into the
film uh I I I'm saying like I think it would have
been more effective with just a rearrangement of
a puzzle like like honestly the first act before
he gets the job and everything leading into when
he gets the job like fine don't change your thing
yeah like that's all great like that that's all
really great that that was when I was like I just
setting up mic it's it's it's solid setting up mic
I like what they changed with Mike's backstory I
think that you got to get a protagonist who you
could care about um like and then they what they
did that I thought was great and it was the odity
that I really loved was when Abby is bonding with
the animatronics and is really getting along with
them and it's like kind of whimsical and a little
peculiar a little bit of a fantasy now and it's
and it's like this is an unexpected bonding and
this is not at all what you what you sort of think
of when you think of Five Nights at Freddy's yeah
and I thought that is where I would have kind
of placed that earlier I'm talking about just a
rearranging of scenes you place that element into
the movie earlier and then it's like maybe there
is something kind of cool here and then there
and then him and then they're actually bonding
with each other because there's this whole thing
about custody battle and and where should they
go and like no I could be a dad look she even
likes my job and then the break-in happens yes
Breakin happens and she's there you or something
like that I don't know who or or well they break
in they both away I'm not saying like I'm I'm
literally not saying change anything other than
the placement of it they break it they break in
and then when they break in that's when you see
them do something horri side yeah that's when you
see them do something horrible and you start to
wonder about it and then you could have your
dream stuff like slowly being in inter related
and then the kids come in later and this movie had
this weird thing where they were like leaning so
heavily into the Supernatural ghost elements first
and foremost at the Forefront and they did no real
like mystery shrouding with the animatronics like
it seemed it got to the point where they just sort
of dropped that kind of early on and they just
put them like front and center so some of the
placement I thought just you would have achieved
I think a lot more of the atonally effective stuff
that I was that I personally subjectively was
craving sure um if they just rearranged some
stuff it's kind of like if if when you're talking
about methan for right I don't know why that's the
one that just keeps coming to mind because I think
that having that scene with Abby bonding with them
made me go well that's what myrian did right was
making you have the Wonder with it and the bond
but imagine if MRI was just like she's evil right
away and and then they tried doing that they'd be
like this is stupid and and and I think here and
then yeah cuz there was like responses that just
felt like not real human responses to things
that I thought were a little no one seemed
that rattled by the fact that there were a bunch
of yeah living animatronics just kicking it and
doing Whimsical stuff yeah the guy gives them the
ride still and I'm like I mean you could pass that
off as like maybe he thinks it's a costume but
it's just so strange that you're like we should
have some other greater acknowledgement of this
yeah because even the scenes themselves I don't
think are NE like like when I'm looking at okay
what do we need in this scene if if if I'm like
looking at an index card of like what do we need
in this scene I'm like okay yeah that's fine so
maybe some dialogue changes sure um like I think
the dialogue definitely could have used a puncha
for some rework sure a little more flavor and I'm
trying to say that like the actual integrity and
the castle on which they are built that house on
which they are building this is actually all fine
it's really they have everything they need yeah
yeah like when I and and sometimes it's just a
a phrase when I'm saying like no actually it's
literally just I think this would have been way
more effective if you just rearranged the way
you unveil your story yeah totally because then
you might be able to a just ring some different
tones and more disconcerting energy out of all
this stuff and you could also maybe generate some
suspense and some actual payoffs because the other
thing is the the way the events are presented in
this order it does kind of I think you said it
one point it seems like this movie feels like it's
trying to sell you a mystery but like the way it's
actually presenting the information isn't that
mysterious and doesn't really lead you to having
too many burning questions you can't already
assume the answers to even I think if you don't
know the story I mean they really established the
whole dreams thing and you know the the five kids
from early on and they each have little totems
that you can pick up on as to you know their
counterparts as the animatronics and stuff and
and I think actually Megan is not that bad of
a touchstone because if you look at what that
movie is it's a you know younger person thrust
in the position of being a single parent to a kid
that they're emotionally distant from and now we
have animatronics filling the Gap there but oh no
something is wrong with that uh and with that one
you just have you know an AI where is this you
actually have ghosty [__] so like it it does
feel like this is perfectly within blumhouse's
wheelous and it does feel like the kind of drama
they tend to present it is like accessible it's
not crazy specific or unique but I think through
the acting but it's not scary it's not and it's
not suspenseful really and it's it's Eerie in
moments it's not at spheric or any there's nothing
really about like here's the thing is what I'm
saying is nothing about this really made me go
how would I put it sometimes you watch a thing
where like the fan base loves it because the fan
base loves a prior and then they're going to watch
this and then they're going to eat it up because
finally it's being brought to life yeah this did
not really do something for me that made me want
to go and explore the the lore even more I did not
mean to do a triple rhy so it's bar but do you
know but do you know what I mean yeah this this
doesn't yeah present you with some kind of deeper
well of mystery you feel like you just scratched
the surface of this presents you as something
that in its again current form and iteration
seems pretty easy to kind of solve and figure out
and nothing really it it's weird there is like a
flatness about it and it's like I thought it was
pretty slick I liked most all of like the shot
composition and even the the editing and stuff I
thought was generally fine and the performances
are pretty good I think Josh hushers is other than
a couple of weird Direction choices with how to re
react to a couple of things uh in certain moments
I think for the most part he gives a really great
performance I think he's a great a great actor
in this and I think Matthew Lillard is is also
extremely I think he's excellent yeah I think
the performances are really solid of them two
yeah and it's it's I guess that's the the most
damning thing about this movie is there are so
many good pieces and everything here even the
stuff that is kind of boilerplate or familiar
the stuff that is less about the specifics of the
game Ln more about like ah it's a movie so we got
to you know give you these emotional eyelines and
stuff like there's something in that where yeah it
never really Rises to anything and everything
yeah just kind of starts to feel like it's on
one Plateau the entire time so it's kind of it's
like a pleasant experience and it's occasionally
strange but it's yeah I I don't know there's
no pulse to it yeah and it's lacks life and
I can't find what the origin of that is because I
I guess you'd go the direction and I thought like
in isolation there were a lot of fine directing
Choice like I don't know what else this director
has done and part of me was wondering like oh yeah
is this the kind of person who who has directed
more I don't know thoughtful horror or or just
independent dramas or something cuz yeah at one
point again you you seemed you pointed out the uh
vibe that like oh these parts in the forest were
were dealing with the actual familial trauma is
seemingly what the movie is most interested in and
is most invigorated by when it's presenting you
know its energy and execution um I it's it's it's
a strange one to look at because there are so many
things that are like pretty good to find about it
and yet it it just it doesn't like yeah I don't
know it it it packs a really light punch nor does
it build up and it's like I don't think weird like
it was predictable and the plot the plot turns and
the the mystery unveilings were really predictable
and obvious and uh yet other than the vessa think
sure just because I didn't know what the [__]
they were doing with her performance I like I I
that was such an odd involved somehow it was so
oddly done the way uh you know uh and it wasn't
it was more like just tell me what's going on
more than what is happening with her like who
is she it got it just reached the point like just
you're you're you're actually frustrating so just
tell me like that's that was the effect that I
had with her um yeah because I hate women yes
especially women in positions of power yeah
well and two I guess there's the other thing
that I guess should be addressed because I don't
know how I'm sure really quick I think we should
interlace it with something more positive so we
somewhat balance sure sure even though we're not
going to do ourselves any favors with it you know
it just sounds like we're mocking it with the way
I'm introducing well I mean it is the animatronics
I think the animatronics are lovely I think they
really brought it to I think aesthetically they
really brought they really brought Freddy's to
life aesthetically they didn't they nailed it they
did mood-wise not really but well and there is a
thing I again I didn't hate this movie I'm not
trying to bash on it like it's yeah it's like
a very tepid positive response for me but I will
say like having I was playing the game again last
night uh oh were you yeah yeah I got the five pack
for for uh switch so I was just like kind of you
know just oh yeah cool so just getting in the mood
and I think as good as the animatronics look and
as Faithfully as they are rendered here they are
scarier looking in the digital Realm whereas here
they actually kind of have the opposite effect
where I'm like well they're kind of endearing
they're kind of cute but that's why the placement
if you put that stuff earlier that could work then
it works draw you in and then you get it and you
get Abby's perspective yeah yeah and then Mike
actually can see a good in like learning about
oh my yeah I wanted a little bit more I think
they could have done a little bit more for their
relationship as characters something I would to
Chang in the writing to yeah like most of what you
get with Josh Hutcherson is this one core memory
this one trauma and yes I only I'm so wrapped
up in in in my lost younger brother that I feel
responsible for that I'm completely neglecting my
actual present sister like you know you could you
could have played more with that but with the
drama there yeah and and I guess what I wonder
because early on I was thinking to myself okay
we've seen especially Wily's wonder I haven't
seen Banana Splits but there are other movies
that do this and I know Wily's Wonderland had
to have had them kind of up in arms in the office
I would imagine going like well how do we make it
different from this and early on I was thinking
like okay cool you take it yeah really lean into
the supernatural make it more like a blumhouse
ghosts type of movie in some respect and there
you H have an opportunity to not have to do the
high octane action disturbing but like that movie
for its rough edges and be movie qualities does
have an intensity and does have like a bigger
scare Factor coming off of the animatronics and
it's funny because I don't think that these two
couldn't coexist and I think it really I think
I think you've ultimately kind of uncovered the
the main thesis of what's not working here and I
wonder why they positioned the events that they
the way that they did because even in times when
I was flashing back two Willies watching this they
would take it in a different direction where it's
like oh yeah the animatronics are just coming out
cool subversion we're just seeing them we're
putting them on the screen we're not doing the
the quisite suspense buildup that we all would
be sitting there going we know these are evil
and blah blah but there's also kind of there
doesn't seem to be a whole lot underneath the
subversions no that they put here no there's
nothing they're just kind of in the immediate
moment sort of disconcerting and then you're like
oh okay well well this is odd I I I just I guess
I didn't feel an an enthusiasm behind the camera
for this one I really didn't I felt like it felt
kind of like when Marvel hires an independent
director to do one of their movies and this was
sort of the Imp and like and that's not what I
associate Blum House with I feel like Blum House
sometimes their failures come in the form of they
didn't do anything to rain this person you know
like that or or I mean you'll get your ones that
are at least purportedly like super boiler plate
like I guess TR Truth or Dare or Fantasy Island
but this this doesn't I didn't get the impression
um damn that is uh oh a woman directed this movie
cool no wonder we we're not feeling strong about
it's our sexism John that's right our sexism for
this movie still starring a dude is it a person
in color so we could come across racist on top of
that too oh I don't know I don't know no doesn't
look that way unless she's white passing who knows
oh thank God okay we're just so she did a Blum sex
not racist thank God if you got to be one you
know it's a lot more understandable yeah on the
internet did interet you can be sexist but you're
being racist and it's hard to get away with that
sexism is a Cornerstone of the internet Community
okay oh yeah no men invented the Internet of all
Races but they were men I think women sometimes
try to do revisionist history here but uh sure
no men invented it so okay she's done a a Blum
House into the dark special and then some other
things that I'm not as familiar with I'm going
to guess like this looks like you know it looks
like she's got at least a bit more uh docu and
dramatic background some horror as well this
not the first horror thing she's done but I feel
like this may I I don't know I thought there was
a confidence behind she do a movie about the Dust
bow I guess so A Plains woman faces the harshness
and isolation of the untamed land in Western cool
I've always wanted to see like a horror movie in
the turn into dust bowl well dude watch the wind I
mean it might be I I would be curious to see this
director's other movies because when I saw her
name pop up at the front I was like oh I don't
know this person but this seems like a neat choice
and this is one of those things where we live in a
time where there are more women getting directing
gigs but they I think often are for like women's
pictures we got to name some women directors we
like to balance the scales okay Jennifer Kent is
amazing Jennifer Kent the invitation is one of
my all-time favorites ological horror movies uh
which is not Jennifer Kent is not it's not Karen
Kus the invitation yeah is Karen kusama yeah oh
wait no who's the one who's made Seven Samurai
in all the great films Tashira mafud or no uh kir
kirawa yeah my favorite woman director K carawa
uh there is K Cawa yeah Emerald finel or uh or
Katherine I mean Katherine Bigalow is a Titan
oh my God so we not sexist thank Goda loved
her remake of Candy Man sure looking forward
to the Marvels as well you know like this is
American Psycho was Rectify Mary Haron yeah good
call O uh Tamara Davis all right good we're not
sexist we've proven our point I feel like I would
be interested to see like I want to know what led
to this person directing this movie not in any
way that I think it was a bad choice because
I feel like so much of was happening in the
construction of the movie and behind the camera
was assured and had some flare and some you know
oomph um and yet just the this presentation of
the story like I don't know this is such a huge
property with merchandising and you know a game
Legacy and it's taken on this whole huge life and
part of me is like I can see this very much being
a movie that the producers are like very involved
with and modulating and tweaking along the way uh
I could see how this might not be in voice you
know a good calling card for a director versus
just in construction or something like that yeah
so I'm watching we're watching the wind trailer
right now without any audio on and this to me does
seem like more of like this looks like a distinct
Vision calculated perspective this is just from
the trailer I'm getting and definitely more the
person who would make the dream sequences and
it would be the person you get to do your F
your animatronic movie yeah I mean I don't want
to be that guy I like I like blem house fans of
the Bob du and the witch are likely to fault like
that I couldn't help but think that if this had
been a 24's Five Nights at Freddy's this would
be this director's movie yeah and I feel like
this director was a solid a quality choice for
a movie like this perhaps are you still bitter
towards Blum House no I like Blum like I feel like
in general Blum House well yeah and I mean we we
all get into why I don't anymore but but no I've
been a blo housee fan for a long time I like a
lot of their stuff I often gravitate toward I know
they have their fair share of Misses but generally
I see Blum House and I'm like yeah let's do this
like I anticipate a blem house maybe not 100% as
much as an a24 but but I I like them both you know
I they get a lot of flak for some reason they've
produced as like a lot of hits for the amount of
flack they get yeah people go like a fing thing
well that often can be good you know I think I
to I tend I've been interrupting you an awful
lot today I'm sorry I I tend to get a lot of flak
uh I I tend to like a lot of their films that even
get a lot of flak is what I'm trying to say well
yeah because I think there is you know what I mean
John what's my opinion uh no I I think that I
would agree because like there are yeah some
are more inspired than others but a fair amount of
the of the more like mid tier blumhouse joints are
ones where I'm like yeah this could be more unique
but for what it is it's perfectly serviceable and
when they are going for that mid-range of the
audience sort of Blockbuster thing with some of
their horror movies I'm here for it you know I'm
often here for it and I'm absolutely willing to
give them the benefit of the doubt and this this
marriage seem like one that makes a lot of sense
pop culturally and where blumhouse is aimed in
terms of their overall demographic you know I
think they skew younger um than maybe like an a24
does but uh I don't know yeah this this felt like
it maybe got lost in a No Man's Land of like what
audience are we supposed to be for because some
people really want this to be an R-rated movie
and it could easily be that and some of that
stuff with the you know the mask and the woring
gears just like a Saw movie or something and yet
I feel like they made a horror movie kind of for
almost nobody except for like the youngest people
who like this game I don't think you needed the
i i n none of it being R-rated as like I I have
I have no issue with that at all honestly like
I think I think just the context alone is you
could do in a PG-13 movie it is unsettling and
creepy you're murdering children transferring
their souls and controlling them after their death
like that that alone with the imagination and the
context is R-rated enough in its Vibe you know the
same way the games are rated teen but they have
a very mature level Twisted lore yeah and that
that's all you need so like even like the way
they had that one person who was like let me look
inside this Freddy mouth uh that that like the way
that death went down and then and if the movie
leaned a little bit more into like the way how
the games would do a bit of the POV of of mystery
and a little bit of shrouded or obscurity or fre
like turning the lights off frequently yeah like
if they if they lean a little bit more into that
when it comes to the violence then you can even
get away with stuff that might seem more violent
than it actually is so there I I had no qualms
at all with it being PG-13 and even experiencing
this I was like nah there's nothing really here
that happened I was like this should have been
R-rated um and we already have that movie you know
well I mean the thing about Five Nights at Freddy
is like when people compare to willly wonder is
that Five Nights at Freddy's is is exceptionally
really into the like when you really dive into
it is so much about its history and the ghosts
and all and and and like the transference of Souls
and and all that stuff whereas Willy Wonderland is
a little bit more direct about like what it's
advertised as and here I I think this movie um
kind of seemed a little disinterested in some of
the actual for initial appeal and then went full
Supernatural Coast movie and and then would like
remind you about animatronic stuff to the point
where it becomes a bit confusing when you're
like is this place evil or is this not quite
evil it was especially became confus and that's
what I mean like it needed some Wonder um it did
it it lacked wonder and and I think when it got
confusing when it was like they spent so much
time with the ghosts of the kids that I think they
should have dialed some of that back it it I'm not
talking about the dream like if you kept them just
like that in the dream world totally cool but I'm
talking about in the actual physical world when
you would see them as ghosts yeah make it less
clear that that's exactly what is going on yeah
yeah and and to the point where I was like why
do they just like act like typical animatronics
at times yeah if they're living in these things
and and they can kind of do as they please kind
of always I get it when there's somebody inside
or whatever and they're doing their thing but
like the rest of the time I feel like things
could be very different for them and what are
they what are they doing you know in these long
stretches where like nobody's there you know
yeah and if they can go into these dream worlds
and stuff why don't they just hang out there all
the time because why the [__] would you want to
hang out in this goddamn boring ass Pizza this
animatronic body and I think they could have I
think they they needed something bold for this
and I feel like they I expected something out
of the whole dream thing beyond that I mean
I like the concept of like oh yeah your body
remembers everything you've ever experienced and
so somewhere buried in there is the memory that
you're looking for however I feel like you could
have and he's taken the medicine and he's sleep
deprived already like you could have done some
reality warping or something like that to really
disconcert us and to throw us off and to and
to yeah get us questioning like okay am I just
conflating these kids with these animatronics or
something because you know the power of suggestion
your brain's crashing things together like there
there's so many opportunities for disconcertion
and confus Fusion that they didn't really seemed
interested in taking yeah yeah definitely yeah
I mean yeah movie's a bit repetitive with the
dream like like the dream stuff was like I get
the whole point is he's repeating this but I I
you get your kns built in but uh yeah yeah but
same time it was like G does just get to a point
where it feels were better yeah yeah totally yeah
he just needs some other element of flavor like
if we did it like three times and then you get a
little further into the memory each time and
then suddenly the show up that's what I mean
instead of introducing that so early and then
the kids show up you're like whoa what is this
you know well yeah cuz it's interesting at first
when you're seeing the dream and it's different
a little bit each time but then once he starts
meeting the kids that kind of goes away and he
adjusts to it in a such a everyone casual manner
so Cas that's what I meant by the ghost thing if
he's just like you're the kids who died right
ghost I don't know how is this happening but I
have a little goal here like that would make he
should have had like a moment of like wait who
the hell are you guys I would doubt my sanity
if I was in this character's position with the
obsession that I have and then seeing these kids
and then being like wait a minute animatronics
and waking I'm taking these Dr like part of me it
was thinking like okay like maybe someone's going
to be like oh it's these drugs man you're seeing
things oh no wait it's not yeah uh or if he was
wondering is this one of the things I didn't
remember are these kids being here I involved
with this yeah instead he kind of just Tak is face
value it's like who are you entering my [__] you
know yeah and uh that was that there were that's
what I mean just like it feels like they wanted to
reduce Peril and yes that that is the problem
with it is like they they got the information
across and like I said I'm talking about like
little tweaks I'm not saying big big like these
little things make major differences yes but
I'm not saying do a major difference on any of
this stuff I'm like you know just T it emphases
here a little bit more reaction here change the
placement up and you got the pretty much this just
a re-edited movie yeah well and people get finicky
about kids in Peril but I feel like this actress
seemed certainly capable enough I think you could
have again for yeah it's a pg3 this a solid PG-13
movie I think you could have presented her more
situations of peril or something especially when
things start to turn sour because some Stakes of
the deaths yeah cuz it even when they're killing
you just know that the four of the PE the guys
who break in you know the other family members
who are trying to you know mess with him and and
you know get him fired you know what's going to
happen to them and the movie seems to know that
you know that and and yeah there's there's no real
sense of danger despite how twisted and Grim all
of this is it's weird it's like somebody telling
you a really harsh story but with like not a lot
of vocal intonation yeah well let's rate it John
Let's rate and call it a day I rate it a 6.7 fair
enough damn that's high I would give it like a six
um I think that uh I like the production design a
lot I think one thing I wasn't expecting was to
be like didn't expect to like Josh Hutcherson's
character as much as I did uh I and it's really
elevated by his performance Matthew Lillard I
wish he was in here more really enjoyed him a lot
great uh I I think while the animatronics could
have been captured with a little bit more mood
and a little bit better buildup I love how they
brought them to life yeah um there was some great
sound design in here and all in all you know like
I think the movie could have felt exceptionally
more convoluted than it actually is you know like
that that is one aspect to this that I think it
could have been so bogged down with just non-stop
Exposition and they managed to not get overly
carried away I would say yeah with it you know
I was like PE the people have made the the the the
history and the backstory and while I know they
changed some stuff sound like an intimidating
Prospect to land into like oh you're you're
opening up like a whole you're going to have to
at least watch like a three-hour video to get part
one to understand the Five Nights at Freddy and
and then so I thought this might be a situation
like that when I was hearing some like I didn't I
didn't feel that at all like I think they managed
to make it digestible so I there's there's lot to
appreciate but at the same time I do think that
there's a a lack of mood a lack of atmosphere
a lack of tension it's not scary I don't it's
not feel like a weird Twilight Zone episode it's
not fun and fun it's like intermittently fun like
there's a moment that can be fun and I mean like
a moment not even really a whole scene yeah uh
it it's there there was nothing unnerving about
it like I don't really know what genre this is
it's it's kind of a it it nor does it feel like
a an interesting splice of genres to me there's
a lot of things about it that I I don't really I I
didn't I found myself becoming more disinterested
as it went along and then they'd be like oh it's
a little thing happened here that was intered and
then I it would go right back to well they two
steps forward like it would be like one step
forward two steps back is how how the experience
kept going for me yeah and so yeah at the end of
the day I I have to be honest with myself and
be like I know that there's a lot of massive
fans when it comes to this but I I would give
it like just a six out of 10 and a lot of that
six is mainly for like the effort for everything
that that they get right barring the actual like
emotional experience of watching it cu cu yeah
like in closing I guess like if it's absolutely
fair to compare these to the games and I think the
games what is charming about them is you have this
crazy ass lore but the immediate moment of playing
it is all just about the suspense and the the you
know kind of butterfly tension of like oh God
who's lurking and when are they going to pop out
of me there's not even jump scares really in this
movie and and looking at this this has three story
by credits and three writer credits one of each
is Scott CN and the director also has a writing
credit I I almost feel like this got sanded down
in drafts and and became what it is so so yeah not
a great adaptation of Five Nights at Freddy's
but like also not terrible just just fine I'm
almost I'm tempted to give it a a flat 50% like a
like a five out of 10 I'm more there but I'm more
there for effort because I can understand like
the the the part of it is that like putting a
you I think at the end you should just judge a
movie based off whatever the final product is
yeah absolutely um I'm G to judge it based off the
treatment I do have I do have no I'm saying that
like yeah having some understanding of the lore
and then seeing some things they had to change
and then having to adapt something like this is
no easy no that's a that's a difficult obstacle
for something like this it really is and I could
see it's easier for us to be in this position and
look at what we're what we just watched and here's
what we would have changed but maybe some of those
changes were happening as they were making it when
they were realizing well this isn't working this
isn't working so we so maybe this was indeed the
best thing they could do at the time because you
you have to deal with scheduling you got to deal
with production you got to deal with a whole B
like there's a whole lot of things that I can
imagine were working against it that maybe this
was the best they they thought they could do as
they were trying to change it to thinking about
some stuff um uh but no I mean overall as a as a
final product like literally the six is for effort
but if on on just an emotional thing I I have no
real strong emotions about what this movie did
for me so I I am emotionally like a five you know
yeah just like lukewarm tepid it's yeah I feel I'm
actually I would say I'm disappointed by that like
I have no dis I have no real strong feeling and is
this is something that were you your main job was
just to make something fun and exciting yeah this
is the kind of movie where you can SK if you get
a couple things right you can skate by a lot of
other things and this is the weird experience
where it gets like a lot of things technically
well crafted and yet misses the one like even one
greater element of whatever suspense fun Etc could
have made this you know the fun you wanted it
to be yeah whereas here yeah you're left with
like God there's so much good work and this all
could have worked really well however you know
yeah yeah yeah at the end of the day uh a little
disappointed with it uh at the same time I'm like
my mind's also going it could have been a lot
worse could have been horrible yeah it's weird
and it doesn't yeah it's it's such a funky movie
because it doesn't feel I don't even feel like
angry about this I'm just kind of like ah this
could have been more I I I I am so very Resolute
is left me in a resigned apathetic mood of just
like whatever I don't really give a [__] that's
where that's where I'm at okay what's next yeah
you know yeah I don't there doesn't leave you with
much to chew on I don't think I'll be ruminating
on this experi but somehow we talked for like 45
minutes well sometimes it t it's this kind of
movie we like what is it what is it about this
that doesn't work somehow we live landed into the
longest discussion we've had in a very long time
yes and there's only two of us so it's okay this
is an important cultural moment it is we'll have a
tight 10 when we watch The Exorcist of [Laughter]
believe um all right guys well what did you think
about this movie uh did you love it as a film uh
what did it do for you uh leave your thoughts down
below and uh hey we'll talk with you all soon
thanks for being here all right John what's the
theme all right all right we're going to shout out
all of our super sexy $10 patrons with a Halloween
party theme and uh We've entered everyone into
chat GPT so it knows all your identities now it's
going to come up with costumes for each of you
based on your name they'll either be something
funny scary or uh it'll be movie related something
like that so uh so here we go I told chat GPT to
keep it snappy let's do this let we're going to
react to it in real time we're going to react to
it all right here's a fun Halloween party shout
out for your super sexy rejects say chat GPT
all right we got namari coming into the party
namari the night walker from a lost episode of
The Twilight Zone you get to look that up for
yourself the CV gun 123 he's the possessed VHS
tape from The Ring PR wi that's actually pretty
invented it's pretty fun we found what CH GPT is
good at rewind at your own risk Mike Joyce Mike
the killer jukebox Joyce every song he plays
fortells a horror tale that's great that's awesome
really great okay FY seur Scissor Hands the Lesser
known even more eccentric cousin of Edward not bad
not B that would be Charming that would be funny
Ryan Smith as Ryan the reanimated straight out
of Frankenstein's lab oh cool Count Adrien Tims
count Adrian from Hotel Transylvania a bit more
fashionable though perfect real nagas as a snake
charmer who accidentally summoned the serpent from
the Black Lagoon W there's like Back stories to
these guys this is so great Heather gear Heather
headless horsewoman that is inventive yes haunting
the streets of Sleepy Hollow Dude the alliteration
today Ian that's a great one I got if any of you
dresses these selling capability pictures a
good suggestion on hallowe costum I'm going
to ask what I should be this year cuz I always
have trouble deciding Ian Simon Ian invisible
the man you feel but never see how do you do that
that's a pickup line right there how do you beat
the invisible s High Glover the s High siren her
songs Le zombies instead of sailors oo I like that
there's just stories to these guys actually you
do an invisible you get a shirt with a collar up
above your head and then you just get a wire and
put some glasses seen people do it pretty good
pretty clever you wear gloves uh hey we got Kayla
King Kayla the king as Kayla the pharaoh's curse
disturb her tomb and face her wrath sexy yeah
that's good and you can depending on your race you
know appropriate some cultures there Allan Ling
and as Allen the alien from the movie They Live
Among Us oo all right it's just movie character
I should watch that movie I like how this decides
between like you are just a movie character
because of your name or we're going to give
you a whole backstory cuz there's not a new movie
character yeah this is just who I think you are so
I'll make up a character based off of that uh Hey
Kier dressed as Kira the Killer Clown pennywise's
competition clever dude cuz there's got to be
someone dressed as Pennywise at the party so you
can challenge Eric K 39 Eric the Extraterrestrial
he's not from around here beautiful he's got a
catchphrase let's let this be the last one Nick
X Nick X The Exorcist got demons call Nick that
is so smart that's mag all right put it away we'll
do the rest on another video I don't want I want
to like reacting to these in real time move the
window John right in front of me my be my be my be
guys thank you for coming to our Halloween party
if any of you dress up like this seriously take
some pics and uh we'll share them somewhere
and uh we love you be well you guys thank
you